did you know
that you're half
mexican yeah
you did
and
you're half what
chinese
[Applause]
who's chinese and who's mexican
[Music]
mama papa
and
and mo and papa
okay you want to know yeah okay so papa
yeah it's
chinese chinese
and i'm mexican you know how i'm mexican
i can dance
yeah yeah let me see can you do your
hips
hey that's the mexican side oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah
okay
you're gonna do chinese
that's awesome
okay and monkey yeah and being part
chinese we celebrate our you
and us this house we're celebrating
your celebrate chinese yes well it's
called
lunar
yeah it's called lunar new year
did you know that
say that
what's that
that means so it means congratulations
and you say that for chinese new year go
kong shi tai
gong shi
hai
say it one at a time
good job
okay so
uh we we're not very um
okay so let me back up growing up i was
very very traditional ray's very
traditionally mexican growing up papa
was also raised very traditionally
chinese almost unrelatably traditional
yes but then when we got older we moved
away from our parents um we got into
super grind mode and it was like times
money so we were like we just want to
build build build build that we didn't
go to movies we didn't go to parties we
didn't do much because
us too and we're fortunate that our
friends
were also grinding with us that we were
just in super work mode super building
mode that we didn't really care to
celebrate many traditions outside of the
ones that we were forced to because the
whole world shut down aka or not the
whole world but at least majority of the
world aka christmas and new year's
honestly those were the only ones we
didn't celebrate birthdays we didn't
celebrate anniversaries when was the
last time we celebrated an anniversary
who knows um i think we celebrated
just a month ago because it was our uh
anniversary but we didn't do anything we
didn't even get each other presents
that's how we celebrate it okay we're
like are we getting any stuff to each
other and we're like nope okay cool
but now as you guys can see taika is
very much grown up he's very coherent
he's making these sentences he's
remembering so many different memories
that now from this point forward i want
to celebrate as much as possible and
carry on whatever traditions i was
raised in and whatever traditions papa
was raised in so that he can bring those
to his future family so one of those is
like we already mentioned uh the lunar
new year
and i'm stoked so i've never celebrated
it papa i think was traumatized by it
because
he grew up doing way too many things
what was yours like you said you did so
one of the things that we did my mom i
think tries to celebrate it like tang
dynasty confucius style where like we'd
wake up and i'd be on my knees for a few
hours pretty much like appreciating all
that we have and um oh and here's here's
kind of a relatable thing i would get
red envelopes from all my family members
right and as a kid you're like yes i
finally there's that toy at toys r us i
can get and you would try to save up all
the red envelopes but my mom ends up
just
taking it
and then she would put it away but my
mom's actually responsible because at
the end of every year she would actually
take me to the bank and deposit it with
me so i would see my bank account grow
and i think by the time i was maybe like
18 i had like seven grand in there nice
that is really crazy okay so because he
was kind of traumatized by it
i never really
cared to ask he didn't really care to
ask about mine we just knew at some
point when kids were starting to get
involved that we'd go back to our roots
and the time has come and it's time to
show taika what we do for chinese new
year aka lunar new year are you ready to
learn yeah
you eat dumplings in chinese how do you
know that you know who's teaching you
where did you hear this
who told you that i didn't know this no
no no are you there from school are you
hearing us talk
did you hear mom and papa talk about it
do you have older friends what's going
on
this is this clearly was not planned
oh the wonder he's five telling you all
secrets
totally not totally not planned i
and skyler's too i did a google search i
brought up all the things that i thought
uh or at least that i read that i was
like whoa this is really cool to carry
on as a tradition and papa is gonna show
me and teach me also how it's all done
he's gonna give me uh the back story on
it and can you share some of your
insight of like how you guys celebrated
it and if you did it this way yes i will
okay
from your five-year-old friend
okay
so one of the first things i read and i
learned taika do you want to learn with
me
okay
is we want to put door couplets and
that's i already kind of started putting
it up you put it on the door and it
should be in twos why is that
so i don't know the twos okay reasoning
but i know something even more
insightful
so what you're supposed to do is
actually have it upside down that's
another one why why is it upside down
tell me uh because it's supposed to ward
off evil or something no
or maybe it is so
because i don't know because you know
like i learned it through my family and
not
food character
yes the food character is upside down
why though i don't know is this it
yeah yes and you know how to say it the
right way
oh my god for reals it is it's fool
really yeah
yeah we're guessing
it's cute
it is
what is going on right now like when
someone's lucky you say
like that yeah
you don't know why that came natural
probably because you're mexican like
what's up
[Laughter]
monkey
but this is the correct way right yes
upside down how cool i know but then
they put it this way so i could hang it
upside down oh wow and you want to know
why it's upside down
so this is the reason why
and it's a play on words a lot of the
traditions in chinese are play on words
yeah so when something has arrived it's
taola
like like like when you're like when you
call your like when you call your mom
when you're like hey are you home
then i go are you home and you go
and also you know what another what also
means
upside down okay so that's why when you
have food when you put it upside down
when you follow it that means the food
is also there so the luck by putting it
upside down is there yeah
so you know what this means the whole
stuff
but after you put it on the wall it's
gonna hang yeah so we're gonna put it on
our door
okay you wanna do it yeah okay
we gotta get i gotta get some tape oh my
gosh oh my gosh stand up right here and
hold up here i'm holding the ladder okay
okay be careful no you i'm be careful
with you of course
okay careful excuse me oh my god
okay wait let me find the middle there
you go upside down
oh that's right side up actually
it needs to be upside down you see how
even the english is right side up
so it needs to be upside down this is
how you hang it
oh okay
we can't do it upside down then we'll
just do it the uh american way yeah
because even the english should be
upside down if it's fully upside down
you know what i'm saying but why is this
hanging this way well that's probably
because it's made for like
the white family that wants to celebrate
happiness google it no no trust me
find them should i do this yeah that's
if my if you did it like that my mom
would be like damn
now that oh that's
that's how you know the chinese family
yup this is how you get chinese street
bread oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
like that
that's the real chinese are you sure
about that yeah the other way was panda
express i don't need to google it nah
nah this is for real friends
you go to taiwan or china this is how
they're gonna roll
the other one
yeah this was the real real you know
what i'm saying yeah i'm careful with
you i'm careful with you okay so we'll
cut this because we don't need that
okay
yeah
oh wait
do you swear it's supposed to be the
other way you swear to god i'm just
kidding
no no that's the right way
that's the right way
you watch we'll go to any other chinese
homies house i'm so happy because your
mom's gonna be so
happy i know
you're such a grown-up right now i don't
like this when you buy a chinese store
dude
okay let's see okay
careful you make me nervous the little
point of the
that's what i picture
what is he saying
okay ready okay so another thing oops
sorry monkey another thing that um i
read is one we're supposed to clean
everything out we're supposed to sweep
all the bad luck out you have to sleep
we will get to that but kind of going
off the topic of decorations everything
needs to be red and gold yes why
that i don't know i do know it's their
lucky colors so any time you're you have
a lucky event in um
chinese tradition
you always go with red so when it comes
to like chinese new year your birthday
getting married you know how when you're
like the bride comes out the bride will
always come out in like a red dress yeah
so that's uh
that's like the significance of red and
gold okay so
red is because it brings happiness
wealth and okay so because of the
spiritual the red can bring happiness
wealth and prosperity by warding off
evil spirits and bad luck i see thank
you google for teaching me about chinese
new year yes
yep so that's what it is so the gold is
wealth red is fortune and happiness sick
and that's why we want to do it okay so
dude
hey food
come here foo where are you
so another thing that we're supposed to
put up
is there you are foreign
paper cuttings off then it represents
luck and happiness is this luck and
happiness on here let me see
uh yes uh no no wait i can't tell some
of the you gotta unravel it's covering
too much of it
ready monkey
okay papa so i got these is this the
cutout of like happiness and
luck girl
decorations it is show pop-up
oh okay so i know exactly what this is
this
also says foo
okay upside down no it says foo in there
in here yeah but do you know what fruit
this is monkey what food is that apple
smart and do you know how to say that in
chinese
[Music]
yeah exactly so you know how i was
telling you in chinese tradition there's
a lot of wordplay yeah so
also is the same word for peaceful so
that's why they use apple because that
signifies
peacefulness you know like you want to
have food which is luck and peace i love
that so in a lot of chinese uh and a lot
of chinese traditions and culture yeah a
lot of work play okay so yeah
i got it from
amazon so we have to construct this so
we'll get to it
good job good job dude
okay so i got another
decoration show pop you know what this
is
a pumpkin a lantern
pumpkin no just a lantern that's not a
pumpkin
what that's for i want this is for the
whole stuff
it's the whole no no no the lantern what
does it mean what is it what is it look
at how this like smells like little
stuff oh okay okay because i have a lot
of wings oh come here here so that's a
lantern
and i actually don't know what the
lantern's for so for those of you guys
that do know comment below why chinese
new year has lanterns
i do know it's up everywhere though but
i don't know uh i think it's to ward off
evil but let me look it up okay
why
okay thank you so i looked it up and
chinese lanterns are hung to symbolize
happiness and are believed to drive out
any bad luck oh cool
going back to the whole sleeping thing
you know how important sweeping is
because it's the the whole action of it
it's so important that obviously we have
modern technology so we'll clean the
house and like vacuum and stuff but the
final part of it um we would like open
the door and actually sweep it up still
still the action of sweeping out bad
stuff
pretty cool huh yeah good to know
all right so taika
invented a way to carry all the lanterns
over here
that's so smart dude
why are you beating yourself
someone's beating you is grandma's
spirit here because that looks like my
childhood
you don't know how happy
i am
to see
a mexican doing this
how did you know because we all know you
don't have a heart you make candy now
this is freaking cuny
because like i like what the mexicans
doing
exactly
and it's cuny because um
you know like
obviously i grew up in this chinese
culture but because i was traumatized by
all the crazy stuff that my mom had me
do
i was never compelled to pass it on to
taika and i although i do want to
um i also just figured like he's still
small so i was waiting i was gonna wait
until he's like five or six or when my
parents fully move here then i can fully
immerse himself
but it's so cuny that ma bear really
wanted to pass traditions on to taika
early so that just you know shows
how cool how cool of a wife
and mom you are and i think that's
freaking cuny thanks
it's fun i mean
i'm
yeah
now i'm just happy that i can do it now
yeah
um and it's a lot of fun and i have a
really
solid why as to why i want to do it
which is you know pass these cool things
on to our son who fortunately has both
cultures to celebrate yeah um
i mean anyone can celebrate whatever
they want right but
it's just so cool that
he has both of this in him yeah that's
so kinney
[Music]
[Music]
that was tyga
[Music]
okay
hey monkey you see all the new
decorations mama put up
that's beautiful huh okay so papa you
said something to me yeah as i was
putting them up i was putting those up
and i know four in
uh japanese korean chinese let me know
if i missed another one maybe even
vietnamese but a lot of asian cultures
uh four is considered bad luck that's
how if you go to asia and you're in an
elevator there's no fourth floor like
there's just they don't want to write
the number four because it
because it's the word on play it also
means death
no it doesn't mean death it's just it's
just word play is so big so four is su
and death is
so it sounds too close yeah too close
okay so i was putting it up and i put it
in four the lanterns are four and i'm
like oh no i'm like but wait i'm not i'm
not finished so i did it symmetrically
if you could see it's not very uh
straight let's give him a bit
to me um i went to eight and as you can
see that little window
only fit one which is nine yes so eight
is a lucky number and so is nine i
thought only even numbers were lucky so
eight is the luckiest
um so it's ba but in cantonese it's far
far which means like blow up ball out
like make hella money so eight is really
really good 100
9 9 is joe which means also a long time
so you can see word play is a big deal
in chinese yeah so it could be like so
like a lot of numbers if it's like eight
eight eight nine nine nine nine that
means ball out for a long time
okay so i left it at eight that's
chinese pager code right now because i
got it because i was about to do
i was about to do 10
because two fit in that other window but
why not leave it at it yeah we're
leaving it at it yeah um and then i had
extra lanterns i was like what if i put
it back there blah blah blah and bart's
like no actually with lanterns you want
to put it at the beginning or at the end
of an entrance yep so then this is
considered the beginning of an entrance
and this is another one the beginning of
an entrance and also
is this considered the beginning of an
entrance i guess so i mean
there's always like the
stick to the books
of traditions
and then there's also like the way you
wing it you know so who knows okay
so i got those up i'm like about pretty
much done with the decorations okay um
there's a few little ones that i want to
add and i'll add those later because it
just takes way too long
another thing i want to do is
a very important one and one that when i
was introduced to this i was like
i'm about it and that is the ever
popular
red cape
so what is it with this red envelope
papa
i don't know the uh
i don't know why they do it but it's
something that you always give and it
goes from elders to juniors
until the junior becomes married and now
they're considered a full-time adult and
now it's their turn to pass on the
tradition so for example i got what it
means okay well i don't know um so the
red color oh it's the red color okay
symbolizes
uh good luck
um oh man this is a long history of it
okay so there's actual denominations in
which you want to give it oh really
so the minimum that you want to do when
it comes to you giving to parents so
usually you start handing out envelopes
once you're married yes um so once you
start giving them to them you give your
parents and denominations of a hundred
to three hundred dollars oh i don't know
yeah um and you want to use
crisp
brand new never circulated
money oh yeah it's always brand new ones
yes then for children it's twenty
dollars oh okay minimum you know and
then for employees or staff or whatever
it could range anywhere from twenty to
two hundred dollars okay and then for
close friends and clothes or relatives
children ten bucks is cool okay and then
for acquaintances or acquaintances
children i guess more acquaintances it's
10 bucks
gotcha that makes sense
yes so and then there's a way to to hand
it and receive it right two hands to
them two hands back yeah wait
hey someone's frozen taika yeah
i got something for you is that for me
yeah what is it
a cat
oh no what's inside okay i'm gonna open
it no so
so this do you know why we do this
this is for lunar new year
so this means
yeah so this means
prosperity
good luck and good luck okay
so whatever say you say
love
no i say shiny and koala
cute and you say to you so now you grab
it with two hands like this
two hands two hands because that's
respect and then what does he take to
say papa you say sheena and kaila she
and kyla good job
so now wait so then you say
thank you yep and that's it you can't
open it and you say thank you you don't
open it like this say [ __ ]
yeah and that's it you put it away
because
yes don't forget about it because it's
seen as bad taste
um if you open it right in front of them
right in front of them so you're
supposed to grab it with two hands or
hand it with your hand to grab it with
two hands she she a bow and then
get out of there get out
yeah
did i do that right
okay
pop up yep um so now it comes to so i
read that like every day
from
the 30 the 30 the first all the way to
the 15th every day it has like a
different thing that you're supposed to
do on the lunar calendar first yes on
the lunar calendar yeah um and every day
something different but to ring in that
new year yeah you're supposed to spend
it with relatives you reunite with them
and then um dinner starts from five
until obviously the next day 12 a.m yes
uh and some of the staples that you have
to have
are
as follows as you can see here you want
to have dumplings
you want to have a fish i can only find
fried fish
yeah you kind of want to steam fish yes
and also the dumplings that technically
isn't a dumpling what
why didn't you tell me what is it
because i wanted to wait uh so this is
this is a xiao long bao so that's not a
it's technically a ball
even though it's so it's like a dumpling
is is
it why did you wait you're so rude i'm
not really skinny you said i wanted to
wait
watch i'm gonna plan the next cinco de
mayo or something and i'm probably gonna
get it wrong i'll bring
you well cinco de mayo is that really
celebrated by american people like no
one in mexico really gives a [ __ ] about
cinco de mayo okay this is like a small
region i'll celebrate that
and i'll probably do it wrong
anyway fine so i messed up yet again
okay so you're supposed to have
dumplings you are a troll um a fish you
want it steamed i know that yeah and if
you're gonna have a whole fish you want
the head and the tail and then that i
don't know why though why is that um
wait what in the
so it's uh it signifies abundance
because fish is pronounced
yeah yeah and it signifies abundance and
it's a sign of prosperity the chinese
believe that uh that tossing you shrink
you sing
prosperity selling i love you okay we'll
bring prosperity wealth and look for the
new year nice okay and then noodles yeah
i know these are also not the right
noodles you just told me that they
should be in this some type of soup
usually they're in a soup but i think
all the noodles are fine so you did do
it right
and you want to eat noodles because it
signifies long life yes one thing you
don't because the noodles are long yes
you don't want to break up these noodles
you want the noodles to be as long as
possible yes um other things that go
along with it is like rice cake rice
wine um
and yeah it looks like i totally botched
this up no i actually think you did a
really good job because all of this
whole chinese new year stuff you've done
more for this naked hairless monkey more
than i have ever done so you already did
a really good job that rice wine thing
that you eat at the end of the meal it's
more like a dessert um it's like a
little sweet fermented rice and then
there's these things called tangy
it's like these little white kind of
like a dumpling thing with the black
sesame on the inside and the reason why
those are important is also wordplay
tang yuen and the word again also means
like
very fulfilled and a very satisfactory
life like grandma like it's perfect like
picture perfect so time you enjoy that's
the thing
okay
um another thing you want to do is you
want to watch like lion dance yeah
that's really cool
yep so sick i love that that's why i
have the dragon up there um
and uh you also want to hey dude you
also want to set off fireworks because
it scares
away evil yes so i want to do that
um
help me
yeah you're going to spill papa's water
duty
um so
another thing you want to do is papa was
emphasizing uh you have to sweep the
floor
why
is it to sweep away all the bad luck and
what are you asking me is you were
telling me you're like why you have to
well i'm so focused on doing it so i do
do it but the why part you know that's
the part i don't know but i'm thinking
it's to sweep away like all the bad luck
from last year because it's a huge
you're doing it you're not supposed to
sweep the floor
what
oh hair must not be washed
i knew that well i didn't know that i
just i read that why okay wait
uh why
let's see that i don't know because we
always clean the hell out of the house
oh you're not supposed to sweep the
floor really you're not supposed to
sweep it because it says the idea that
you sweep out luck if you sweep on new
year's day maybe you're supposed to do
it before new year's yeah before new
year's oh okay okay the first guest in
your home to the new year's day fills an
important role in the coming year
oh
so that i don't know but uh he said that
the person sometimes called the first
footer foretells the kind of luck you
can expect during the next 12 months
yeah don't let anybody come in
yeah that stuff i don't know but we had
a huge emphasis on cleaning the house
before like the week before and you want
to [ __ ] and span and you want to get
all the bad luck all the bad juju out
and there's a huge emphasis on starting
the new year like new and crushing it
yes so you're not supposed to shower
yeah um because then you're gonna wash
away your luck
and you want to wear new clothes like
you said
um
and
yes we're gonna clean everything washing
clothes we're gonna ring in the new year
in new clothes
and um that's all i got did i miss
anything nope
okay so this was kind of
like
a b-minus
i thought it was pretty good well i
messed up the whole dinner part
i mean that's hard to get right okay
okay but at least i have a hang of it so
i know next year for sure is gonna be
super cool yeah could it be like me like
ordering like a traditional mexican
dinner and i just go out and get a bunch
of tacos and burritos and stuff you know
whereas i don't know it might be like uh
what is it like something verde or like
carnitas or my you know or you know i
just don't know i'm just ordering what i
basically know fair thank you
well this was fun mike monkey did you
like chinese new year did you like
everything we did the decorations the
food the envelope
well i hope you learned something and
how do you say it again
she me and kaila
she didn't quite
thank you
thank you goodbye everyone